me right now that proud boys are not
allowed at this trump event i'm telling
you right now any sort of proud boys or
qan and cigna
yeah has to go all right so i'm gonna
leave i'm gonna leave but we were
invited we were invited to be here i'm
gonna walk out they probably didn't tell
you about problems
we were walking out towards the doors
okay so why why why do i have to walk
why do i have to walk because the front
doors are this direction sir that's why
no i mean like why why do proud boys
have to watch well it's because you
can't have any logos or insignia for
this event and the people hosting this
event
you're kidding me right because the
trump campaign gave us vip tickets you
can turn your shirt inside out or you
can purchase another shirt this is
really happening you can leave
it's really happening okay okay so can i
ask why proud boys aren't allowed here
it's the logo it's the shirt and i don't
make them sorry
but we're we're giving you some options
is there is there a reason why proud
boys aren't allowed here it's a private
event they made the rules man that's all
that's all i could say but the actual
campaign themselves gave us vip tickets
so why is it
why can't
i watched a video yesterday
you see our title of our show is proud
boys cry more and he's [ __ ] in cell
white nationalist it is really it is
really something there's a couple videos
out there of the proud boys from this
nra convention one where that trump
basically told him to go [ __ ] themselves
um you know during the presidential
debate he's like stand back and stand by
now he's like no stand over there go
over there i don't want you anywhere
near me i look like a traitor when you
people are standing next to me i did
that's not a good look he won't even let
cueing on people in his entire [ __ ]
base his entire base the proud boys and
q and on like that who who else is there
gonna vote for this [ __ ] who
else is gonna support this this clown
besides people who believe in q anon the
crazy wackadoo [ __ ] and the proud boys
told them to go get [ __ ] and really
it's not about having the people in
right this has nothing to do with what
type of people they associate with they
really want to associate with white
nationalists they really want to
associate with terrorists domestic
terrorist groups like the proud boys and
the oath keepers they just don't want to
appear that way it would be really nice
proud boys if you guys didn't dress up
and do the cosplay proud boy thing you
know put on a different costume is what
he really wants them to do the same way
with the q anon he definitely wants the
q and on crazy he just doesn't want the
costuming he thinks it's gross he thinks
they look trashy he thinks they're not
classy coming from a guy who has gold
toilets have you ever seen pictures of
the inside of this guy's house you you
talk you talk about [ __ ] trashy holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is the epitome of
white class trash
you know we're talking about the proud
boys do you think they really thought
about that name before they picked it
out like i don't think they did i mean
here's the thing their logo is a [ __ ]
wait wait who's
the proud voice what what yeah no it's a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
stop hold up wait a minute you're
telling me because i i i'm not i i have
not done this much research into this
their logo is is designed after a penis
is that what you're saying it's not
after a penis it's a [ __ ] rooster or
whatever but oh a kite
oh
[Music]
i thought you meant they were walking
around with penises all over them and no
who knows i mean i mean i'm not against
it i think i think that would actually
be funnier than the [ __ ] chicken
right but they have this [ __ ] rooster
right as their logo right so that's why
i say [ __ ] when they were like let's
name ourselves brown boys and they're
like what what mascot can we have that
represents us as proud boys manly men
who who absolutely are [ __ ] white
nationalists who hate right yeah they're
like
they're like what is more american farms
farmers are pretty american that's
pretty manly and they're like well
what's the thing that gets you up in the
morning and they're like you know
someone people like a little pill you
know somebody i'll be like oh it's a
rooster a [ __ ]
and then they were like and then they're
like oh yeah yeah that's a good [ __ ] you
know you know what pisses me off about
the proud boy thing because we're joking
about it but what pisses me off is um
the leader gavin what the hell was his
name yeah gavin mcginnis gavin
mcguinness the guy who found it didn't
he didn't he like do something with the
dildo to prove that he's not gay or some
[ __ ] yes on on air which i will not
bring up the clip and show on here
because i'm sure we'll get flat for it
right yeah youtube would not like that
to prove that gavin mcinnes was not gay
he shoved a dildo into his ass on
television live streamed it what pisses
me off about that kind of [ __ ] is that
these people believe that it's the it's
somehow like the physical sex and that's
where they get this they they start
these tropes with lgbtq people that
they're predators and [ __ ] because they
think it's like it's not always about
the physical sex you [ __ ] idiot like
they love a person right they have
feelings for a person they have
attraction to a certain person and a
certain gender
they really because they're so
frightened of their own insecurities
that they don't understand that it
almost feels like to me you know we joke
about it but it almost feels like to me
they were trying to
steal away the the pride that someone
would have to not be afraid to express
their sexuality express their their
identity i am excited that it is pride
month and don't let the prowboy steal
this away even though that name is now
associated with
domestic terrorists and white
nationalists